always great to welcome back to the
program bill scher contributing editor
to political magazine and contributor to
Real Clear Politics bill you've got this
new piece in Politico the issue
Democrats wish would go away can the
Democratic Party retake Congress by
giving up on gun control we are starting
to see this sort of right now actually
in the special elections that are going
on talk to us a little bit about that
and sort of my general thought going in
was as I started to read the article is
there something about where these
special elections are taking place that
might explain that and I'm curious
whether you think that the answer to
that is yes or no does this happen to be
because of the special elections were
looking at or is this a a trend we're
seeing on the Democratic Party staying
away from gun control well the former is
definitely true and geography explains
all of that it's an open question
whether that's going to inform the party
in general as they try to take back more
plausibly the house in 2018 you have we
had a situation not long ago where a
candidate for mayor of Omaha Keith Mello
had an anti-abortion voting record in
the state legislature gets an
endorsement from the DNC and Bernie
Sanders saying this guy's a bonafide
progressive and the pro-choice community
led by a RAL uh you know had led a
massive backlash prompting the DNC to
say you know support for reproductive
freedom is not negotiable
no matter the city or state but when it
comes to guns you know James Thompson in
Kansas was was brandishing an assault
rifle we'll talk about personal freedom
in his ads Rob Quist
is caressing an old Winchester rifle in
his ad talking about his Second
Amendment rights and John Asaf has
generally downplayed the issue when he's
asked about gun control he says well I
grew up in the house of firearms and I
would support legislation that keeps us
safe and protects our Second Amendment
rights although he did oppose the campus
arrey bill in georgia is one area where
to a gun control slide but generally
speaking
you've down playing so you're and you're
not seeing the activists left criticize
rob Quist and john Asaf and james
thompson for these stances the way the
heath mellow got hit with abortion so
why is it different you so you can
partially explain that by the geography
obviously they're doing the stances that
makes sense for their localities but
that kind of electoral pragmatism is not
in play with some of these other
subjects would this be allowed on on the
right in the opposite in other words if
you had a republican that checked off
all the right litmus test boxes so to
speak for a reliable republican
candidate except they were very much in
favor of more aggressive gun safety
legislation or whatever the case may be
might the same exception be made on the
other side that seems to be made here by
democrats well you know you generally
know but you susan collins exists yeah
she's been a moderate senator from Maine
for a long time and she doesn't get
denied financial support from the
Republican Party it is standard practice
to allow Running Room to people based on
local concerns like that that's not
unusual and and so in a narrow sense
it's it's no big deal that it's all
running in Montana is going to be
running on a on a gun right stance the
question is is the party prepared to
downplay the issue overall the next time
there is a public mass shooting which we
haven't had in about a year you know we
had a situation where you know after
Bill Clinton passed the Brady Bill and
the assault weapons ban there is an
argument that that hurt Al Gore in 2000
in Arkansas and Tennessee in West
Virginia Democrats began to downplay the
issue generally when the assault weapons
ban came up for renewal in 2004 the
fight for that was very HAP ha R 'td
when you had several pro-gun rights
cats win key Senate races in 2006 Obama
downplayed the issue in 2008 and when we
had Aurora and Gabby Giffords and Fort
Hood in his first term there was not a
concerted push for gun control in his
first term it was not until Sandy Hook
after he was reelected when gun control
became a top priority issue for
Democrats so on one hand you could say
look it's just localities but - there
are a lot of localities there are a lot
younger me out there we're pro-gun
stance is the logical position to take
and at some point it tips into becoming
a deep prioritization of the issue for
the party when we think about this from
a strategy perspective at the national
level you know on the one hand we had
polling I guess it was a couple of years
ago where on the question of background
checks on every single gun sale slash
purchase there was like 85 or 88 percent
agreement nationally that that's
something that we should have and yet in
that environment and maybe this is more
like three or four years ago now that
I'm thinking even in that environment a
Congress was not able to pass mandatory
background checks on every purchase and
sale of a gun so does that suggest that
maybe it's from a strategic perspective
logical to downplay this issue because
even when you had the possibility
politically of passing something as
fundamental as 100% background check
coverage after a mass shooting by the
way after the Sandy Hook shooting for
example it still wasn't done maybe it
makes sense fatigue eclis - not to
downplay this issue well right this this
is the hard question that Democrats have
to grapple with that gun control
activists have to grapple with look
after Sandy Hook one of the most
traumatic events in modern memory people
thought that perhaps the political
equation had changed and if Holly
Democrats are asking for the moon after
that we they they were pushing a very
narrow background check bill that had
support from a bipartisan duo Joe
Manchin and Pat Toomey who both
previously had a ratings from the NRA
it was poll-tested up and down it had
that broad support in poles you couldn't
you couldn't line up your ducks any
better and you still could not get it
past and that's a guess that the poll
numbers don't fully inform how the
public and the politicians are going to
act because uh in a vacuum most will say
sure background checks but in the face
of a massive NRA push that doesn't talk
about the narrow issue but treats guns
as a cultural touchstone a symbol of
your independence a symbol of your
personal freedom to protect yourself
from crime that makes the issue so much
harder and so even after that failure of
manchin-toomey hillary clinton ran the
most overtly pro-gun control campaign of
any presidential candidate since
arguably al gore though that's there's
some debate about how fervent he was
there I the NRA was with Donald Trump's
biggest outside supporter I and and that
bet paid off for them so you can so you
just really litigate and say well maybe
it wasn't really the guns but how do you
separate the gun issue from these
broader cultural issues involving a
cultural East versus rural America and
immigrants and race a lot of it is
bundled up together and you're seeing in
these special elections Democrats like
Rob Quest saying look I don't I don't
want to re-litigate that stuff let's get
that issue off the table and if the next
time there's a public mass shooting of
Democrats and out of one mind on this
subject it's going to be very divisive
for the party isn't there another
strategic layer to this as well which is
that you could argue that not having
Democrats out there talking about gun
control legislation actually leads to
fewer gun sales in the sense that or as
evidenced by the record gun sales under
Obama under the now obviously false
pretext that he's coming to take your
guns compared to numerous gun
manufacturers saying you know what gun
sales are down under trump without the
constant fear mongering around democrats
coming to take our guns people actually
aren't buying as many guns
III haven't seen the most recent numbers
May it's only been a few months but it
wouldn't shock me that you get these
spikes you got a spike when Bill Clinton
came into office you're going to spike
win when Obama came into office because
there's this massive freakout you know
they're coming to take your guns away
which never actually happens of course
but that's what the fear-mongering says
but you might well have another gun
incident another mass shooting I mean we
already were do need to be McCobb about
it but you know we know we haven't gone
more than a year between public mass
shootings under Obama it's been almost a
year now so hate to predict such a thing
but it's likely there's going to be one
and people on the left tend to react and
say this shows we need to crack down on
guns but there are a lot of people who
see that and say this means I need to
get a gun right because they might be
coming for me that might seem you
totally irrational and I agree it's
totally rational there's no evidence
that owning guns going to make you
personally safer but a lot of people
believe that we are going to have to see
as we get closer to the 2018 midterms I
think bill if there is some sort of
cohesive narrative from Democratic
candidates and it might might be
different from incumbent Democrats and
those who are challenging incumbents in
terms of what the narrative will be but
this is going to become a bigger and
bigger thing over the next six to nine
months as the midterms heat up isn't it
well it this is an issue
unlike abortion and other issues out
there in the world by you know a
reproductive rights is an issue that is
on a lot of people's minds all the time
you know ninety nine percent of people
use contraception there's almost a
million abortions every year those
numbers run down dramatically over the
years and part because of the wide use
of contraception but it's still pretty a
sizable number yeah they're not that
many gun deaths there's not a million
gun deaths every year it's about it's
about thirty thousand gun deaths every
year so it's not top of mind in the
public psyche until there's a public
mass shooting and look public mass
shootings are a sliver of the number of
gun deaths most of them are suicides but
that's what makes it a shoe that you
talk about that you feel
urgency about and you don't know exactly
when those things are going to happen is
going to be close to Election Day or not
so it is it going to be the issue 2018 I
can't say but certainly my my sense is
Democrats are not prepared to deal with
it if it is a top of mine issue because
they haven't thought through how to deal
with it after the failure of
manchin-toomey and the failure of
Hillary Clinton to win on a gun control
message no doubt about that check out
Bill shares article in Politico the
issue Democrats wish would go away can
the Democratic Party retake Congress by
giving up on gun control should it bill
always a pleasure thank you